Hey youtubers it’s charlie since there’s
been so much news about the flash tv series
I wanted to do a big update on which actors
have been cast, who their characters are and
how the show is taking a different approach
to the dc universe than Arrow.
Also heads up, I’m still collecting questions
for my Arrow Q&A, so feel free to write flash-related
questions in the comments and I’ll include
a few in that video.
If you’re finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get it.
So let’s start with the cast.
Most everyone is associated with the most
current New 52 versions of the characters.
Everybody knows about grant gustin playing
barry allen.
Unless the arrow writers bring him back for
a cameo in the final episodes of season 2,
he’s still in a coma.
Presumably he would wake up during the flash
pilot and his story would begin by discovering
how his powers work and his quest to solve
the mystery of his mother’s death.
Those two things will be the biggest stories
during season 1.
On to the main villain.
In a surprising twist, they’re not holding
anything back.
They cast Rick Cosnett as Eddie Thawe, also
known as professor zoom or the reverse flash.
He’s like the flash’s joker.
His greatest enemy.
I’m so pumped he’s on the show this soon.
The professor zoom character is a huge part
of the flash’s new 52 origin story.
I don’t want to spoil what his role in that
is, but you can read all about it in the comics
starting with The newest version of the flash
comic book.
On the show, Barry and Eddie will both work
in the Central City police department.
The character description makes it sound like
he won’t reveal himself as professor zoom
right away.
Then there’s Detective West and his daughter
Iris West.
Jesse Martin will play detective west who
will be a mentor to Barry and Iris is played
by Candice Patton.
She’ll be barry’s best friend where season
1 picks up.
It’s unclear how of their backstories from
the comics will be in the show.
They might change a few things because there’s
this big time travel and pre-destination paradox
aspect to Iris’ character.
Be sure to read the comic if you want to learn
more about it.
But let’s just say that every major event
in their lives as well as their existence
all loops back on itself in this giant mobius
strip of cause and effect with professor zoom
at the center.
Now is a good time to mention that the show
will be much more hard science-fiction than
Arrow just because of the time travel aspects
of the story and the speed force.
So think of it as like a super hero CSI technical
show crossed with arrow.
The other characters they’ve cast so far
also include Danielle panabaker, she’s one
of the mid-level villains caitlin snow.
She’s Killer Frost in the comics.
She’s a STAR Labs bioengineer who’s husband
died in the particle accelerator explosion.
I don’t know if they’re going to show
her getting her powers during season 1 or
if she’ll already have them when it starts.
Carlos Valdes is going to be Cisco Ramon,
the vibe character a lot of you have been
asking me about.
He’s like the barry allen of star labs.
Really young, really smart and just like Killer
Frost they haven’t said whether or not he’ll
have his powers when the show starts or if
he’ll get them in an ‘accident’.
They might alter the character a little to
make the particle accelerator explosion the
source of his powers.
Because in the comics he got them after being
exposed to a boom tube.
Which is the interdimensional gateway opened
using a mother box.
Which invokes darkside and all this other
crazy DC canon that is way too much for the
show.
So bet on them dumbing it down a little.
Those won’t be the only characters on the
show, but they will be the main characters.
They’ve already been shooting the pilot
episode and Grant Gustin even tweeted a picture
of the script.
The series is planned for a Fall 2014 debut,
but nothing has been confirmed.
If they don’t air the pilot this spring
after the arrow season finale then they’ll
at least screen it at comic con.
Ideally the show will just air back to back
with arrow whenever season 3 starts.
So cross your fingers that the pilot gets
picked up for a full series order and they
start filming episodes soon.
We’ll probably know whether or not that
happens before the end of arrow season 2.
Now let’s talk some Arrow Crossover, a lot
of you have been asking about Balicity and
characters going back and forth.
So first, Felicity and Barry will still be
a thing.
That will be the connective tissue between
shows.
There will probably be a minor Felicity cameo,
maybe Oliver.
For the most part both shows will have separate
storylines.
But felicity will reference events on the
flash from time to time.
The creative force behind both shows is largely
the same, but they’ll have different production
teams and different writers.
Virtually all of the arrow characters and
villains will stay on arrow exclusively, the
flash show will introduce it’s own villains
including big bad professor zoom and killer
frost.
But remember Arrow didn’t go crazy with
super villains in season 1, so expect the
same thing from the flash.
Just with way more science fiction.
I hope all that answered most of your bigger
questions about the who and whats of the flash.
I’ll be doing video updates for it as new
information comes in, be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
Right now click here for the most recent arrow
video and click here for the q&a video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!